tu es sûr qu'il y a une pression qui est
présente mais un enfant à la fois les
intervenants de la protection de la
jeunesse ne veulent laisser personne
passer entre les mailles du filet mais
les dossiers à traiter sont de plus en
plus nombreux en hausse depuis quelques
années les signalements de la DPJ
dépassent maintenant les 135000 pour
l'ensemble de la province toutefois un
signalement ne veut pas dire
automatiquement qu'un enfant se remplacé
sous la protection de la jeunesse à
Montréal où l'on fait le plus de
signalements c'est presque la moitié des
cas de 2022 2023 qui ont été référés à
des organismes communautaires notre
population a besoin de savoir les
services qui existent les organismes
communautaires qui existent et il faut
miser sur la prévention à la DPJ on
constate qu'il y a une hausse de
détresse familiale de violences
conjugales et même de violence à
caractère sexuel qui mène à plus de
signalement mais pour certains le réseau
communautaire n'est pas la solution
miracle manque surtout beaucoup de
financement des organismes
communautaires pour qu'ils répondent
efficacement aux besoins également
c'est quand même encore une grande
méfiance je crois aussi on va les
services de la protection de la jeunesse
à Montréal l'évaluation de signalement
se fait en moyenne en 27 jours mais avec
presque 20 000 signalements et 30 postes
à combler dans une équipe qui devrait en
avoir une centaine la liste d'attente
compte présentement 520 enfants la
directrice assure qu'aucun camp urgent
n'est en attente on a mis en place deux
intervenants qui font des appels au
signalant deux semaines plus tard on va
l'appeler pour voir est-ce que la
situation de l'enfant s'est détériorée
et s'ils la situation de l'enfant s'est
détériorée on va s'assurer de prioriser
cet enfant le temps d'attente est
beaucoup plus long pour les services en
anglais à Montréal sans environ une
centaine de jours pour une évaluation il
y a présentement 20 postes à combler
dans une équipe qui devra rencontrer 39
selon la directrice nationale de la
protection de la jeunesse la situation
est également critique en Outaouais
puisque là encore il faut trouver des
intervenants qui sont bilingues ici
Carla Oliveira au Canada Montréal